frustriert weil hier weiß keiner
bescheid
geht man zu condor wissen die net geht
man zuerst wissen die auch nix also den
streik an sich ist es nicht so das
problem eher das außen rum so eben
fluggesellschaft reisegruppe so dass da
wo es bekannt waren wahrscheinlich auch
nicht die erste streik war passieren man
sich alleine gestellt für unsere
forderung heißt dass wir einen
stundenlohn von 20 euro für die
beschäftigten in der luftsicherheit
fordern für die kolleginnen und kollegen
die tagtäglich passagiere waren compact
und personal kontrollieren wir halten
diese forderung für nicht so hoch wir
finden sie es gerechtfertigt das muss
uns die sicherheit an den flughäfen auch
wert sein einverständnis ehrlich schon
klar ich mein man möchte ja schon das
geld bekommen für das man ja auch
arbeitet und nicht irgendwie
unterbezahlt sein aber es halt mal bild
wenn das dann uns betrifft halt die ja
nichts damit zu tun haben
reisen irgendwann kommt ich denke mir
klar ist es blöd gelaufen ich meine das
ist jetzt gerade bei uns halt auch mit
erwischt aber prinzipiell bin ich mal
jemand ich find's schön dass alle
steigen
wir sehen das problem in der airline
dass die da ein bisschen an der
organisation einfach gescheitert ist das
ist unsere also meine meinung auf jeden
fall dazu zu dem ganzen thema
dieser arbeitskampf war notwendig die
haben ja begonnenen warnstreiks unter
vier stunden in berlin haben die sehr
frühzeitig angekündigt haben auch alle
anderen arbeitskämpfe angekündigt
rechtzeitig frühzeitig damit passagiere
die möglichkeit haben um zu planen und
wir haben zwischen den streiktag auch
immer wieder den luftraum sich beruhigen
lassen damit die leute ihre ziele auch
tatsächlich noch erreichen
daher sind wir hier nicht irgendwie
maßlos unterwegs ist sind noch
warnstreiks jetzt zwar ganztägig aber
wir sind hier immer sehr früh was die
ankündigung betrifft
im schlimmsten fall werden wir natürlich
abwägen müssen ob wir die arbeitskampf
aktionen nicht weiter ausweiten und die
streiks ausweiten